hey youtubers it's Charlie welcome to
emergency anime club episode three since
there are so many anime series that are
either getting rebooted or coming back
like fate/stay Black Butler Sailor Moon
I thought it's fun to talk about our
favorite reboots
first things first congratulations to
last week's winners of the random
giveaway McNee you won the studio ghibli
DVD and Izzy gaga and you get to pick a
future anime club video topic I'll be
contacting both you guys for details but
this week I'll be giving away random
figure from the crunchyroll store so
here we go drinks up let's get started
top 5 anime reboots number 5 Evangelion
the TV series original ending was so
confusing that the first film was made
to provide some clarity it wasn't really
until the second film that I was blown
away that film is the reason I put this
on my list that being said most of the
reviews of the third film make it sound
like it goes way overboard on the
visuals and it's kind of hard to follow
like one giant boss fight there is a
fourth movie being made for 2015 so
hopefully that will address some of the
criticisms I mean you can't just spend
all of your time in a boss fight
character development is really
important for a good series number 4
JoJo's bizarre adventures the OVA series
from 2000 still holds up today
originally there were two OVA stories
but they told a single story the funny
thing is is that the newer series from
2000 told the first half of that story
so there's this weird effect where the
animation quality drops dramatically as
you reach the second half of the story
but both of this really classic
hand-drawn 90s style my favorite aspect
of that story was the stand their spirit
companions you know they could be
objects or humanoid or they could even
be elements number three stand alone
complex I'm talking about the Laughing
Man arc specifically I was a huge fan of
the film and the Laughing Man episodes
really embodied all the best things from
that the character designs were changed
a little bit just to resemble the manga
versions a little more closely and
because the series didn't have the time
constraints of a movie the character
development was so much better my only
real complaint against this series this
is the way they plot the Laughing Man
arc episodes and the standalone episodes
it was just a little confusing number 2
Hunter x Hunter there's so many things
to love about this mostly the character
development which is amazing it actually
follows this classic Shonen style where
you see Gahan evolve over time it's not
just jumping from one battle to the next
but the battles are actually really
awesome too they're plotted out in this
really strategy
way that reminds me of some of my
favorite RPG games this is a really good
anime series to watch if you want a
really simple story but with just
amazing characters and an amazing
soundtrack I actually listen to the OST
whenever I'm playing video games
sometimes and my number one favorite
remake Brotherhood in my opinion best
anime remake of all time a lot of the
fandom considers Brotherhood to be a
much truer adaptation of the manga it
also introduces a lot of new characters
throughout its run which is really rare
for an anime series if you have a friend
that really wants to get into anime but
doesn't know where to start this would
be the perfect series to show them and
it's all on Netflix even though there
were a ton of characters by the end all
of them were really well developed and
three-dimensional even the villains had
hearts and clear intentions and as an
added bonus the dubbed versions are good
really good most of the time I would say
stick to the subs just because the
original voice cast tends to be better
but in this case the Brotherhood dubs
really hold up the only real criticism I
have of it is that the animation on the
early episodes isn't quite as
spectacular as the original but I think
they might have just been trying to save
money for later episodes everything
still looks great it's just that the
animation on this first couple of
episodes is a bit of a weak point now
it's your turn let me know what is your
favorite anime reboot or sequel in the
comments below and as a bonus question
it's still running right now but how
would you feel about a reboot of the
original avatar last airbender series I
mean the first story next week for anime
club I'll be doing my top 10 anime
characters be sure to subscribe to get
my video I don't know what I'm gonna be
giving away yet but it'll be the same
deal as this time there'll be a random
Prize winner and then one person will
get to pick a future anime club topic
right now click here for anime club
episode 2 and click here for anime club
episode 1 thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight for space
dandy high fives
that tastes good